hi there today we're looking at
adversarial examples are not bugs
they are features by Andrew Elias at all
so this paper is pretty interesting as a
catchy title and we try to kind of
dissect what it says so first of all in
the abstract they say adversarial
examples have attracted significant
attention but the reasons for their
existence and pervasiveness remain
unclear so if you don't know what an
adversarial example is an adversarial
example is basically the following say
have an image classifier right
classifier boom internetwork image here
and the image is of a let's say a cat
all right this is my best attempt at a
cut bank cat and you feed it through the
classifier and the classifier says cat
now if you perturb this image if you
derive an image from it and you perturb
it just very slightly very subtly so you
introduce some pixels here they're here
they're ready to change some pixels in a
very targeted way and you feed that new
image through here then the classifier
will say dog or something really you can
make it say anything like airplane or I
don't know sky or whatever you want
these are called adversarial examples
and it's true their existence and
provide the reasons for their existence
and pervasiveness remain unclear they
say we demonstrate that adversarial
examples can be directly attributed to
the presence of non robust features so
they're basically they're paper is about
these non robust features and they they
define later what they mean exactly but
here they say features derived from
patterns in the data distribution that
are highly predictive yet brittle and
incomprehensible to humans and this is
this pretty arm needs so the fundamental
idea as I understand it and I'm gonna
you know take this
away right here that if you have images
let's say here of cats and I'm gonna I'm
going to draw another one over here if
you have an image say of cats there is
multiple features in this image and the
feature is something that the classifier
can pick up on and kind of learn to this
is a horrible can learn to learn to
classify images from so features that we
humans generally use are a cat has ear
ear eyes whiskers right and the general
relationship to each other of these
things is this what constitutes a cat
and that's how we classify but also they
say there are other features that are
also very indicative right if you think
what differentiates a cat from a dog and
the dog here that's like fluffy ears
also eyes yeah not gonna go further with
the dog too much the what differentiates
kept from a dog and we of course we
would say well the head shape is
different and the ears are different and
the relationship to them to each other
or different but it could also be and
this is a simplistic right now alright
but it's also that cats for example have
different further than dogs and yeah
being overly simplistic here but bear
with me so let's say in our hypothetical
world cats have fur that all goes like
this left to right right every hair is
basically vertical sorry horizontal if
you look at it like that and dog fur on
the other hand is always like this right
is is vertical right top to bottom and
so the classifier might just as well
pick up on the fur direction in order to
classify images right since all cats
have that type of fur and all dogs have
that other type of fur that classifier
might just as well pick up
on that right and to us humans we don't
really pay attention to these things
because they're minut ready don't look
at the directions of individual hairs to
classify in an animal to cat or dog you
you much rather go for these kind of
large features like where are the ears
how do they look and so on but the
classifier there isn't actually you can
make an argument that the classifier
would more likely pick up on the fur
direction right in order to in order to
classify it since we're using
convolutional neural networks and
they're generally neighborhood pixel
neighborhood operators it came much
easier pick up on these patterns than it
can on the general relationship of the
of the large features so if a classifier
now learns that cats always have fur
like this and dogs always have fur like
that what we could do is we cannot go
over here to the dog and change its fur
like chain in the image change its fur
to this direction now to us humans that
would still very much look like a dog
because the fur Direction is almost
imperceptible but did the classifier
that has only learned hey a cat always
has this type of fur and the dog always
has that type of fur that new image
would totally look like a cat all right
so this paper argues exactly that this
paper argues that in the dataset there
are features and these are real features
like this this actually could be the
case that cat's fur is all always like
the attic dog's fur is always like this
it could be the case and the classifier
could pick up on this right and then the
adversarial examples the reason why they
exist is because the classifier has
picked up on these imperceptible
features and so by changing the features
we can change the classifiers decision
in without changing the image in a large
scale so they they say that they make
this hypothesis and they kind of they
say ok we established a widespread
existence in standard data sets so they
kind of give supporting evidence for
their hypothesis
and they they say finally we present a
simple setting which is a theoretical
setting where we can rigorously tie the
phenomena we observe to a misalignment
between the human specified notion of
robustness and the inherent geometry of
the data all right so it's kind of
different pieces of the of this paper
and we're gonna look at them in
succession so the introduction we
largely skip except that their main
claim here is specifically we claim that
adversarial vulnerability is a direct
result of our models sensitivity to well
generalizing features in the data so
that's the core point I think is well
generalizing features which is what we
mentioned these are features that
actually describe the data well but but
features that are kind of imperceptibly
small to humans or that don't fit our
notion of robustness all right so they
go on and did define more clearly what
they mean here whenever we talk of a
feature right remember we had the our
classifier here then we input an image
and the image let's call X right and
that classifier usually if we look at it
closer consists of multiple layers of
interconnected neurons whatever and the
last layer will be an output layer in
two different classes right and so the
features when they say a feature what
they mean specifically is the last here
the last representation before it goes
into the classifier so the way you clap
you would classify them and here they
just accept establish a two class
setting the way you would establish that
is you have feature one feature two
feature three and you have a weight
vector W one for each feature W 2 W 3
you make the inner product and that will
give you a Y hat basically if that is
high you say it's class 1 if that is low
you say its class -1 so
classes here are plus one and minus one
just to make things simple so but you
see the features or basically what comes
out after these layers what is then used
to make a linear classification this
last thing is basically just a logistic
regression
you can think of the features at the
output of the neural network but before
it goes into the classifier so a feature
basically since then it's linearly
classified if the feature is high it
will give a signal for one class and if
a feature is low it will give a signal
for the other class depending on of
course if this w is negative or positive
all right so they say we call a feature
rho u s-- 'fl and if this thing holds
here and what is this thing this thing
means so the expectation over the dates
so generally in the dataset this must
hold Y times the feature so Y is the
class and remember it's plus or minus 1
and the feature as we seen is some some
number Y times the feature must be
higher than some some number so what
does it mean when a product is high it
means either both or high or both are
low so they're correlated that that's
what that means so basically this is
says a feature F is useful if whenever
it at an example X is of class 1 if its
class class 1 or let's if it if y is 1
plus 1 then F is high and whenever y is
minus 1 then F is low which means it's
high in the negative direction alright
so it is this is around this is
intuitive right if a feature is useful
it means it should say one thing in
samples of class 1 and it should say
another thing in samples of class 2 then
I can actually use the feature to make a
decision when it
you know very correlated with the class
so that you know that makes perfect
sense so that's kind of when is a
feature useful if it correlates with the
class label yes cool but the usefulness
simply any feature basically that a
class fare will extract will be useful
that's an assumption we can make
otherwise the classifier wouldn't
extract it
so the neural network here that's an
assumption will only extract useful
features all right because um the non
useful features there would simply be no
reason for it to extract them because
they don't contribute to solving the
task because they're not correlated with
an output class right so next they
define robust robustly useful features
so in addition to being useful there now
also robust what does it mean again we
want a correlation of Y and the feature
to be higher than some constant but not
only the feature of the image X but the
feature of the image X that has been
perturbed by a small perturbation so and
we take the the infinim here over a
class of perturbations of course this
class of perturbation see exactly the
adversarial perturbations basically what
this means is it says that however we
try to perturb X right and the infinite
mirror means that the minimum
correlation however we try to make the
feature not correlated with Y however
much we try we can't get it lower than
some some gamma some number right we
can't we can't get it down so whatever
we try to make the feature bad for the
classifier basically we can't write if
this holds for a feature if this is the
case then we call that feature a robust
feature right then that feature is
robustly useful if it correlates no
matter how hard we try to make it
correlate and of course a non robust
features so a useful non robust feature
is a feature which is useful you see
here is useful but is not comma robust
feature for any gamma so it is a feature
that is useful like take the cat fur
right so this year an example of this
would be that the cat's eyes and ear
position right we can't just make a
small perturbation for the image and
make the ears be somewhere completely
else that's just that would require a
large perturbation of the image so the
position of the ears and eyes are really
robust features but here the cat's fur
no matter how no matter how small we we
make this discover we can always kind of
change the fur to make the feature not
rope to make the feature not useful
right if we can change the cat fur into
a dog fur and the dog fur into a cat fur
then the feature will become not useful
anymore because we can you know we can
we can change that orbit really for any
image and then the classifier will have
no clue it can't be like well this fur
could be of any of any class right so
the feature is not useful anymore so
this is a non robust feature the
technically you can say any feature that
is useful but not robust is a non robust
feature all right so this is kind of the
definition of what robust and non robust
heat rays are yeah remember maybe
remember robust features like position
of the ears and their shape and non
robust features would be which direction
are the individual hairs in the fur
going right in in our world where cat
fur is going different ways than dog fur
so they're now going to experimental
evidence for their for their hypothesis
and here you have to understand they do
two experiments which give pretty good
indication
their hypothesis is actually correct and
what you have to understand before this
is is two things first of all here you
basically you just have to assume that
they already they have some procedure
where they can do the following where
they can take an image of the training
dataset and they can decompose it into
its robust and non robust features right
don't i mean don't ask yet how they do
this but they can decompose it into
these two parts all right so that's
assumption one they have a procedure
that can actually do that and then
number two is what they what they do
here is basically the general theme of
these experiments is they they have a
training data set right this is the
original training is they create a
derived version of it so let's put a
tick here this is a derived version of
the dataset then they train a regular
neural network with that so what you can
do with a neural network if you train
one all right what you usually do is you
feed images X you feed images in it
gives you some output Y hat and you say
well but I know Y is the true label so I
feed an image of a cat that the network
says airplane you say well but this
should be a cat so please make this Y
more to be more to be please make this Y
hat more be like Y and then you have a
loss function here you say this is wrong
please correct this you back propagate
and all the network in here will update
to make that a bit more likely that's
how you train usually in a real at work
now what you can do is if you want to
become robust to adversarial examples
you can do what is called adversarial
training which means that you have the
same network here but of each of the
training data points you create
a derived version an adversarial example
to that to this X you feed the
adversarial examples through the network
together with the original examples then
this will give you some y hat - and then
you say but this should also be equal to
Y so basically you train the classifier
also on adversarial examples right
since the hypothesis is if you train on
a image data set then you can teach the
classifier about that data set right
like you do with the regular data set
you say well ok I can now just trained
on adversarial examples and my
classifier will be able to better
classify these correctly right this
usually works it's called adversarial
training and it's been a kind of a
standard method to make your classifier
robust they don't do that here they
don't do this they simply want to say ok
we now have we have a regular training
procedure right like this except for
what we change is here the training data
set we change this to in in one case for
example only robust images so we've
changed all the X to be only robust and
we do the regular training procedure and
then we evaluate that resulting
classifier here this thing we evaluate
that how does that behave so it's kind
of a new approach where you modify the
the original data set so what did I do
first of all they decomposed this
training data set into a version that is
only robust features right we we assume
we have such a procedure we then train a
regular neural network on that right we
train a regular neural network on this
on this dataset and what we get is two
things first of all good standard
accuracy what is good standard accuracy
mean it means that
we we can test it on what's called the
unmodified test set so deep the tests at
the original test set of the dataset the
test set belonging to this training
dataset we can test it on that and it
works just fine right so that basically
means that the robust features are
predictive of the of the kind of um they
generalize well it means that if I train
a classifier only on robust features
that can actually classify well to um to
the to the test set right so that means
that's standard accuracy standard
accuracy is how well do I classify the
test set just an unmodified test set
so they also obtain good robust accuracy
which means that what is robust accuracy
robust accuracy means your accuracy on
adversarial examples of the test set and
usually classifiers are vulnerable to
this classifier is usually obtained good
standard accuracy but bad robust
accuracy but if I only train my
classifier on what they call robust
features then I all of a sudden had
retained good standard accuracy but I
also get good robust accuracy which
means that it gives pretty good support
to their hypothesis that the adversarial
examples are abusing the fact that the
classifier has learned the non robust
features since if I don't have any known
robust features it means my classifier
can't learn any non robust features
which in turn means my classifier isn't
vulnerable to adversarial attacks
because they would abuse the fact that
the classifier has learned about the non
robust features so that's pretty good
evidence for their hypothesis the second
thing they do is they now create this on
this modified data set where they only
have known robust features all right so
the only thing they have is non robust
features again they terrain a
standard neural network they trained
just a regular neural network on that
and they also get good standard accuracy
so this means that also the non robust
features as we seen like the cat's fur
direction can lead to you generalize
well to the test set since in the test
set also the cats will have that um that
property but you get bad robust accuracy
and this this gives further support to
their apophysis if you train a
classifier on only non robust features
they are features because they
generalize well but they are very
vulnerable because they are non robust
right so the classifier that has learned
about non robust features is vulnerable
they didn't do a third experiment which
I find pretty cool where they take they
take the training image and of course it
it's an unmodified training image so
it's robust features will basically say
this is a dog it's non robust features
will also say this is a dog because it
you know it's a it's a training image of
a dog and what they then do is they
derive from this dog an adversarial
example towards the cat class right so
what does it mean in their hypothesis if
their hypothesis is correct it now means
that the robust features still say it's
a dog we can also see this here right
the the kind of big shape of the image
still is a dog to us humans but the non
robust features will say it's a cat
right this hinges on their hypothesis
that adversarial examples actually abuse
the non robust features right they
create an adversarial examples if there
are offices is correct the non robust
features now say that's a cat
so they derive a an entire data set
where they change every image to another
image and they also change the labels
accordingly and then they train again
Giller neural network on this and they
look what happens on the unmodified test
set
so the unmodified tests at will so
imagine if you your the your this
classifier and what you get is an image
X and it has robust features that's a
dog and has non robust HS a cat and its
label you're asked to predict cat right
and then we see the next image and the
next image X to the non robust features
maybe it's derived from some other class
it will say plain but the the robust the
non robust features against a cat right
and you're asked to predict cat so
basically the constructor data set where
the non robust features always agree
with with the label but the robust
features they don't so naturally what
you can expect is the classifier will
learn to disregard the robust features
because they're no longer useful right
but it will actually only will learn to
view these features it's different from
before before we only had these features
now we these features are still in there
right but they're not informative so the
classifier will naturally learn to pick
up on the non robust features and
classify and classify according to them
so much that if we now test on the test
set and we feed in an actual cat right
it's of course it's robust features
we'll say cat and it's non robust
features we'll say cat and the
classifier is able to accurately predict
this is a cat even though the all the
images of cats it has seen during
training or actually of basically of non
cats of here a dog right so this is
pretty cool and shows that kind of these
these features that these non robust
features that adversarial examples abuse
since they're created by adversarial
examples they they are actually
predictive and generalize to the test
set so that's pretty pretty good
evidence for there have
offices so far now the kind of final
remaining question is how do they create
what is the procedure where they can
create a robust and then basically non
robust version of the data set and here
is kind of where we get into the into
the sort of what I find yeah so here you
see basically examples of so this is an
original image of a ship in the sea for
10 data set I believe and this is a
robust sample so these are only robust
features of the ship and this is a ship
made with only non robust features you
see is actually a moose but the non
robust features have been changed to
ship all right so the way they construct
a robust version of the data set they
have a formal definition but the way
they do it is as follows
so and then they say ok here is where we
where we get into the details they say
imagine we have a classifier right the
classifier outputs features and here we
call them here they call them G which is
the represent ik it can be larger than
features it can be a bigger class but in
essence G is the features which then
goes into the into the classifier and
into the labels and so on so the D
neural network outputs the features
inputs some X now what if what if I have
another X let's say X Prime and I just
initialize this with random noise and if
I feed this and I get G Prime here and I
try to make the 2 as close as possible
by changing X so I'm gonna change my X
here basically I'm going to change my
image such that they outputs the
features here match each other as close
as possible what does it mean and I do
this via back propagation right I match
these and I back propagate to X I can do
that with gradient descent what happens
is
that my image X will basically pick up
will match the image my X prime will
match the X in all the ways that are
relevant for the features basically I
will transfer all of the features from X
to X Prime but nothing else right since
I start with random now what if my
classifier and that's what they do what
if the classifier is a robust classifier
so remember we talked about we can
actually robust defy a classifier by
doing adversarial training what if I
have a classifier it's like such that is
robust if I input an X and it outputs me
a feature representation of X if the
classifier is robust that representation
will only contain robust features and
then if I have a second image X or and I
started from random noise and I match
the representation of X and by by
changing X R basically I will transfer
all of the robust features from X but
nothing else right given that I start
from random noise here this means random
noise has no features not me that's the
assumption random noise has no feature
since its random noise and if I transfer
only the robust features basically what
I've done is I've um I've have now an
image that I know has no non robust
features and only robust features of X
so that's how they derive a how they
derive a robusta fide version of X
second how do they derive a non robust
version and that's even even easier if I
have a classifier write a regular
classifier and I want a non robust
version of X I have X input output
I'll put some label what I do is I
simply derive an adversarial example of
X like we did before adversarial example
in here out here and that gives me some
act y2 which is different from Y right
if I have a adversarial example then
basically I've transferred I've
transferred the non robust features that
lead to class why - I've transferred the
non robust features here while still
maintaining the robust features from
here so if this is too abstract imagine
here X is an image of a dog right dog
and I derived from it an adversarial
image that now says airplane right so
the robust features will still be of a
dog will still be of the original image
but the non robust features will be of
the airplane class all right so that's
how I derive a non robust non robust
version that has features of kind of one
robust features of one class but non
robust features of the other class
that's what you see up here with the
moose right the Moose clearly has been
started from the image of the moose and
then has been has received non robust
features from the shape class and that's
just your classic adversarial example
procedure so that's the that's the kind
of procedure and so what's kind of my
criticism here if you look at the first
part the first part where they say well
in order to determine what the robust
features are we actually need a
classifier that's already robust so
we've seen before we have a we have a
data set sorry let's go up here they say
aha here we have a data set right and we
can disentangle this and then it will
which color every not used we have a
data set we only we robust if I the
dataset to a robust dataset we train a
standard neural network and that gives
us good robust accuracy Y which is
really cool because we don't do anything
special during training and we still get
good robust accuracy but in order to do
this procedure here this one you
actually have to have a robust
classifier right you have to have this
already robust defied classifier which
you have obtained by adversarially
training the robust classifier basically
what you're doing now is you take this
adversarial training procedure which the
point here is that you don't do anything
different during training right but here
you take the adversarial training
procedure and via training the robust
classifier and VR changing this dataset
here you basically get good robust
accuracy which to me is just a
reflection that you've obtained the
dataset using this robust classifier in
the first place
I mean yeah of course their their method
gives a hint that I can actually this is
actually do two things in the dataset
themselves right but there I mean that's
really important because it surely means
that it's not a point of let's say the
the classifier itself but its point of
the dataset which also say okay it also
explains why these adversarial examples
transfer between classifiers if you have
two classifiers that are different but
classify the same thing they're
vulnerable to the same adversarial
example which basically means it must be
some property of the dataset that these
things learn but to do then say we have
a procedure to extract the robust
features and if we only trained on the
robust features we become robust right
as here but you obtain the robust
features by using a robust defied
classifier which have adversarially
trained to me that's kind of kind of
backdooring adversarial training
into this whole procedure and yeah so
that's kind of my first criticism my
second criticism is the fact that even
though I mean it's it's an interesting
take on this but this whole notion this
whole seeing of these features are
robust these features are non robust
it's basically just reframing the
problem of adversarial examples in terms
of in terms of features it says nothing
why these features are there simply
accept simply postulating that they're
there it says nothing why they're there
it says nothing about why the
classifiers pick up on them or how they
do it or how you know how this is to be
mitigated without first having a
robustly trained network to extract the
robust features so it basically just
shoves the problem into the realm of the
dataset rather than in from the realm of
the classifiers so it's it's very much
widely or not things are very much
widely not known about these samples
it's just a reframing of the problem I
feel and it's it's cool experiments I
mean they it does show some a lot of
things about these adverse aerial
examples but certainly not an
explanation I find at least that's my
opinion
all right so down here then they show
that they make an and kind of simplified
version of this a theoretical setting
where they can analyze this and they
basically say okay this is generally
what happens at the fundamental level at
the fundamental level you have classes
and let's say the classes are
distributed like like this right this
these are the examples in the data set
and they're distributed like that right
the other mean and you have some
covariance
these are gaussians here so they're
distributed like that if I have two
classes like this such as here right and
they're distributed like that and I
create like this
operator a linear classifier the linear
classifier will classify like this it
will be like super this is the best
linear classifier right we can calculate
this accurately but what do I say when I
say okay I want an adversarial example
adversarial examples means that I can
shift my examples by a little bit but
achieve a big change in output and since
since this distance here right so if I
have a sample here I need to go a long
way to the boundary to achieve another
output but if I go into another
direction right if I go down here I only
need to go a very short way and since
adversarial examples as they're
specified they say okay as we want to go
a short way in the short way is
characterized by going a short way in
any direction right this is a terrible
circle in any direction we want to go a
short way that's an adversarial example
and you see that if I have this any
Direction property there is actually
directions where this classification
boundary is very very close and so
that's what they say this is a
fundamental misalignment between the
geometry of the data which is like this
and the geometry of how we specify
adversarial examples which is you know
kind of equal in each direction which
leads to that and they say ok what if I
now robust parameters so what if I
adversary train my network to be robust
it basically means that I expand my data
because I add adversarial examples right
of this circle here I actually add
adversarial examples so my my class my
data distribution of actually more like
this and my separating hyperplane will
change here and the geometry of the
adversarial examples will be much more
aligned with my separating hyperplane so
this is kind of a toy example of where
they say this is fundamentally what's
going on there's a misalignment between
the geometry of the
for several examples and the inherent
geometry of the data so that's kind of
the the theoretical analysis they do and
with that I finish here and I hope this
was clear enough and goodbye